[Music]  don't see you fish thank you two months  dip a bug in it  boom green beer here's bill with another  tip take a glass of motor oil put some  whipped cream on top  boom Guinness that would be more  expensive here's another one get paid to  act like a jackass for 22 years  boom luck of the Irish  [Applause]  I should look at these before I air them  there's another one  take a beef patty watch it perform a  miracle boom st. patty take your friend  Danny dressing like a kid boom Danny Boy  [Music]  please don't say money and their stupid  apparently here's the last one take a  two leaf clover drink a bottle of  Jameson  [Applause]  boom four-leaf clover  [Applause]  you  you